what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the first part of sins of
sinister and this story is amazing okay
so check this out so one of the things
to remember with sins of sinister is
that what Mr Sinister have been doing is
that one there's four of them not just
one and each one believes that they are
like the main Sinister but the Sinister
that we know with the diamond on his
head that he had basically been duping
the X-Men that every time an X-Men was
killed and then brought back to life or
really any Mutant was killed and brought
back to life that they had a gene
planted inside of them that would allow
Sinister to take control of them right
to literally control their mind and so
what we saw in the original one shot
that said all this in motion is that
over the years in Marvel Comics going
into the future that Sinister had used
this to basically conquer the world and
then ultimately his Creations
essentially turned against him so what
this does is this basically picks up in
the time when the X-Men are conquering
everything it is really like a Civil War
in a lot of ways and the reason why is
because this one focuses on storm so
what we know about storm for the most
part is that she resides on Mars she's
like the queen of the Iraqi people the
other half of the mutant population that
we simply didn't know existed but in the
early days of sinister's forces taking
over the world that as they were going
through and attacking different groups
though one of the first groups they
attacked were the group of the Iraqi on
Mars because they're some of the most
powerful mutants in existence so getting
rid of them as fast as possible is the
best way to kind of clear the landscape
and make Conquest easier for sinister
and all of his forces and so what storm
talks about here is that she recalls
back to when the quiet Council seem to
be getting more and more extreme she
didn't actually know that Sinister had
been controlling them she just felt like
the Kawaii Council had moved away from
trying to turn uh krakowa into a place
where mutants could reside in safety
from the mutant population and it
started going on a mission of conquest
and so one storm had realized that
Sinister was controlling the quiet
Council she immediate retreated when she
realized there was no way to destroy
them but when Destiny the precognitive
showed up and told her now is not the
time to attack that storm started
marshaling her forces and initially they
were just gonna wait right they were
gonna take Destiny's advice and just
wait for the best time to attack but of
course Sinister attacked them using
Chimera now Chimera are basically the
examples of where Sinister is taking
different mutants and merging them
together we'll learn more about that in
the nightcrawlers comic which is amazing
like it looks like it's gonna be so cool
I'm so excited to read it but of course
as you would expect by having a chimera
of mutants the forces of storm are
almost completely and totally
obliterated and they have a whole host
of people at their disposal it includes
Richard Ryder Nova people like that but
because blending Omega Level mutants
together and in effect they are greater
than the sum of their parts means the
forces of storm never really even had a
chance they never quite had a chance to
even overcome these guys us and so all
that's left here is death and
destruction the only thing that storm
and her forces what's left of them could
possibly do was just Flee for their
lives but with them just kind of out
there and basically remade in Hidden the
way this works is by way of whiz kid now
whiz kid we've talked about before but
it's kind of a refresher here this was a
kid that has the ability to create and
control any kind of Machinery he can
possibly imagine there's no limit there
so you could even argue he's Way Beyond
Tony Stark or Reed Richards or any of
those guys but the long and short of
this is that he was able to develop a
cloaking device that would in effect
hide the storm and her Brotherhood from
the forces of sinister they'd never be
able to locate them and so what we end
up finding out here is that Destiny has
approached storm yet again but this time
storm is a little more apprehensive
because the last time she took took
Destiny's advice they were ambushed and
almost the entirety of her and her
forces were eradicated and so what's so
crazy crazy about this is that while
this meeting is taking place between
storm and Destiny that storm asked this
guy named John if it really is Destiny
herself and John's response is it's not
now we don't really know anything about
this guy we'll talk about him here in a
second but he immediately attacks
Destiny because he senses a few things
one her uh her energy signature is not
the same her mannerisms are different
right there are things about her body
language and so on and so forth none of
it looks like Destiny or even sounds
like Destiny if you're paying close
enough attention now when this guy makes
his move we end up finding out that it's
not Destiny it's actually a Mystique and
this particular guy isn't his named John
ironfire now again we don't really know
anything about him he's just one of
these mutants that seemingly existed out
there in Cocoa but Marvel heavily
heavily implies the idea that this guy
is Omega Level in fact Mystique
literally asks though I thought only
omegas could serve on the great Ring is
this a rule that died with your planet
or are you the Omega of molten metal
blood now there's different ways to
interpret this one is of course the rule
that only Omega Level mutants can serve
on the great Ring of oracco is no longer
intact it's literally storm just
marshaling whoever she can and forming
the council out of whoever's left so
being able to pick and choose about what
person you have just isn't quite there
it could also be this guy quite
literally is an Omega Level Newton and I
would argue that is the latter and the
reason why is because John has the
ability to create any metal in existence
using his own blood now there's nothing
to directly indicate that he can or
cannot create adamantium but it's
possible he could actually blend
adamantium with other metals mysterium
or vibranium or something like that and
actually create a whole new form of
metal that's never been seen before
that's more durable than adamantium or
any of those but the long and shorter
that's the reason why this is so cool is
because what we end up getting is
Mystique who's here with a mission for
storm now one of the things to know is
that storm under any normal circumstance
would never jeopardize her forces she
would never jeopardize any of her guys
what's left of her forces she would
never send them on some kind of random
errant but what Mystique reveals here is
the true power of sinister that with
Sinister it's not simply just taking
everybody under mind control and then
trying to conquer the world the reality
here is he could fail multiple times for
any number of reasons and in light of
the fact that he could fail he has a
kind of reset that he developed remember
one of the things that Jonathan Hickman
established in his run on the X-Men
which we turned into a full story is
like 13 hours if you haven't seen it
already there's a link to it down in the
description it covers the entirety of
Jonathan Hickman's run of the X-Men but
one of the things he established is that
Maura McTaggart who in years past was
just a mutant geneticist and a really
good friend of Professor X the leader of
the X-Men that she was actually a mutant
and her power is that every time she
died the timeline reset and she would
basically come back as her but
remembering everything that had happened
before this is sinister's McGuffin right
it says Ace in the Hole if for whatever
reason he were to fail he can basically
just activate one of the Clones of more
mctaggard and then kill her and that'll
reset everything but Sinister will
remember it all he'll remember
everything that that clone of more
McTaggart remembers basically everything
that's happened so it gives him the
ability to kind of reset everything to
zero but correct the mistakes that he
made and so knowing this that seemingly
storm comes to the realization of what
Mystique is saying that so long as the
Clones of sinister are in his possession
there's no conceivable way they could
win there's no possible way they could
come out on top every time they defeat
Sinister if he somehow manages to escape
one of the Clones will die everything
will get reset and they'll ultimately
end up taking or he'll ultimately end up
launching his campaign all over again
and so with the face of that knowledge
there's only one thing storm can do
which is launch an attack now this is
when we get into the Brotherhood
themselves and in truth it's composed of
some pretty Heavy Hitters right so right
off the bat you've got storm who is of
course an Omega Level mutant that can
control the weather on any world that
she's on and even manipulate whether
that happens in space right storms and
different things like that you've got
cable who speaks for himself right for
those of you guys who don't know who
know who cable is he's one of the most
powerful telepaths on telekinetics in
the history of Marvel Comics Cora of
course is not Cora from The Legend of
Korra she's not a bender uh or an avatar
even though she was nowhere near as
interesting as king uh not not Kang
there we go
King the Conqueror The Last Airbender
which is a story I would absolutely read
uh the core has the ability to boost the
power of anybody in her vicinity and
move it to a higher level of course with
kid we've already talked about iron fire
we've already talked about quick
basically uh lulo Marshall she's
basically the fastest being that's still
living right so seemingly Quicksilver is
no longer alive here and then of course
you've got Mystique who's not really
officially part of the Brotherhood but
it's just kind of there along for the
rod but the thing about this is that as
everybody shows up here right once they
arrive to where uh sinister's base is
which is actually a more mctaggers
former base of operations as soon as
they show up there we end up finding
that Chimera are guarding the place
specifically it's maggot and Marrow who
have been merged into one now this is
crazy because one of the things Miro was
able to do in Marvel Comics and she's
basically old school
um she could kind of grow bones out of
her body that she could like throw at
you but maggot had the ability and
really it was only only came in the form
of two but he had these kind of maggots
that would basically consume energy for
him but they could consume anything in
existence it didn't matter what it was
and that energy once they consumed it
would be fed back into uh into maggot
himself which would basically either
sustain him or even bolster his own
abilities but the thing about this is
that by combining the two is quite
literally having maggot bones thrown at
you these bones will be thrown at you
and they will consume you it's a pretty
dangerous thing right imagine somebody
just throwing piranha that could eat
anything in the world or anything in
existence imagine them throwing uh
throwing those at you and that's what
you're facing off against right now it's
a pretty wicked combination and I love
the idea right I honestly kind of hope
this is going to be one of those Age of
Apocalypse types things where like some
of these folks survive into the main
timeline when this kind of future ends
or is somehow averted or whatever the
case happens to be and we get them going
forward into the future of Marvel Comics
because it'd be on amazing
honestly I can't really even remember
the last time that I talked about like
maggot mirror or any of those guys but
again once Storm's forces overcome them
overcome those Chimera they get into the
base of operations they meet even more
but the bigger issue here is that with
the cloning system of sinister it's
basically met with an impenetrable force
field and so the cool thing about this
is that as this discussion Goes Down And
as we're trying to figure out what to do
here what Wizkid does is he comes up
with this idea of instead of trying to
like take down the force field which
they just don't have time to do to sit
there and run like a whole bunch of
algorithms and try to figure out the
best and most effective way to do it
because the forces are closing in they
can only hold them off for so long that
what ends up happening is that instead
the Brotherhood basically teleports the
whole system away right they teleport
the entire uh cloning facility away so
during the sins of sinister one shot
when Sinister came back to his base of
operations and the entire cloning
facility was gone and then he was now
stuck in this timeline this is how it
happened right it had seemingly happened
quite some time before Sinister himself
realized what was going on right because
by the time he realized that his cloning
facility had gone something like 50
years or so had passed or 10 years or
something to that effect so it's been
gone for quite a while but the other
part of this is that as storm and whiz
kid are watching the system teleport and
then preparing to make their leave we
end up finding out Wizkid is not
actually whiz kid that whiz kid is
Mystique impersonating Wizkid not only
that here's the cool thing about this
right she literally kind of taunts John
by asking were you able to figure out
that it was me this time and the reason
for the reason for why John was able to
deduce that it was not Destiny and
actually Mystique was because Mystique
allowed him to and I imagine those are
the guys who are probably watching this
or listening to this or even read the
comic when it first came out you were
kind of like no way some random mutant
is going going to be able to figure out
that like it's not Destiny and that is
actually a Mystique unless there were
some kind of telepath because Mystique
is far too Adept in her powers to simply
just figure out that it's someone else
somebody like Wolverine could do it just
by picking up sense but then again over
the years in Marvel Comics we've seen
mystique's abilities move to a place
where she can even trick Wolverine now
the only real person out there who's a
shape-shifter who's so capable that no
one can really figure out who they are
outside of some high level telepath
would be like Vanessa Carlisle right
like copycat the girlfriend of Deadpool
in the the fox Deadpool films that's the
only one who can really do it because
copycat cannot just copy the physical
form of a mutant she can also copy their
powers right so she can literally block
her existence or anybody that she's uh
that she's copying from like any
telepath if she's duplicating a telepath
right so it's cool right she can like
copy the powers of Charles Xavier and
have some measure of telepathy but after
basically stabbing storm and seemingly
killing her this basically leads to
Mystique Body sliding by one out of that
location I.E teleporting away and then
of course John Ironside runs to the side
of storm and while she's not dead of
course the goal is to get a medical Evac
in there so they can get her out of
there get her treatment and get her
healed again and so at that point we
jump to Destiny and we have Destiny
basically here at the world Farm now
remember the world Farm is a place out
there on the far reaches of the universe
right at the very edge of the universe
and what we end up finding out is that
Destiny Ever the precog and ever aware
of what's going on around her and always
looking to the Horizon right that's one
of the things about Destiny while
everybody's running around and focusing
on the here and now she's 10 steps ahead
almost every single time that's her gift
and her role of being able to see and
understand the future as always and one
of the things I want to mention here if
Destiny tells you something's gonna
happen in five minutes take it as an
absolute truth if she tells you
something's gonna happen in five years
keep it in the back of your head because
it may not come to fruition but Destiny
is always on the move and she's always
being Guided by her Visions it's why the
old Destiny diary story and the X-Men
Comics were so important those of you
guys who remember the destiny diary
stories those were great back in the day
it was really cool one of the last great
X-Men stories before the huge reboot
with House of M but the thing about this
is that of course Destiny being here at
the world Farm we end up finding out
that she's talking to one of the other
sinisters specifically the one with the
Spade on his head and so it's kind of
crazy here because this is basically one
of the sinisters seemingly aware of what
the other Sinister is doing but trying
to find a way to bring his campaign to
an end we don't know fully what role
he's going to play or how far reaching
his actions are or if he's just hiding
the fact that he wants to do exactly
what Sinister did but wants to see the
diamond Sinister taken out but whatever
the case is I'm sure we'll find out by
the end of this story but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
peace